can I talk to you about relationships
yeah we already have so yeah I know but
more generally speaking we didn't get a
chance to talk about the the red pill
Community oh sure well first of all what
is the replica Community the manosphere
in general I'd love to get both of your
opinions on this sure
I I know I know you're probably not as
opinionated
do you think I am that like probably not
as you like as much as you but I I do
have opinions yeah you do okay I usually
don't like speak out too much on it
because I feel like there's like a
language barrier I don't I that's why I
don't really do politics because this is
my second language yeah that's right you
have to know the a little bit like you
know how to use you have to use
derogatory terms every other sentence
yeah so they understand you right
exactly and that's yes you need like a
good like you need to be able to like
speak really well for people to take
your seriously I think and like that's
the thing like if I if I don't have like
the words and I don't have the like I
can't pronounce things correctly yeah
I'm searching for words look stupid
essentially so that's how people view it
yeah tell me about it I have a podcast
people listen to and I mumble and they
yeah wait is here what's your first
language Russian oh okay but I speak
both languages horribly I'm just not
I'm not like there's definitely a big
disconnect between my brain and my mouth
module like I'm not able to generate the
thoughts efficiently like the things
you're able to do like speak like that
I'm not
it's very very tough plus there's a huge
amount of anxiety and social interaction
that I have which makes speaking even
harder
yeah yeah yeah it's tough I understand
it gotcha okay it makes sense yeah the
the gotcha is both a symbol of
compassion and derision at once I'm just
letting you know I understand what you
said I'm just gonna sit there and stare
at you confirm no you can just say like
yeah I get it like yeah yeah I get it
yeah
no it's so it's so short I got you say
say it longer sentence but that means
the same thing I understand you yeah
that's good that's like not chills you
know you get chills so yeah you
understand me yeah it feels good yeah I
hear you I hear you and like if you just
like call the other person's hand that's
even better you gotta put in some
emotion there okay show that you have
some
what do you think about
gotcha what do you think about red pill
uh what what uh sorry what what is it
first of all for people I don't know
yeah the red pill Community obviously
it's the Matrix reference the red pill
that you take is when you realize what
dating standards and Norms really are in
the world that men are providers and
have to become some great thing to hunt
and attract you know the woman who are
just kind of there floating around
looking for people to give them the most
resources and it's like coming to a
realization of what the world of dating
really is broken away from the Hollywood
standards and the romantic stuff that
they try to sell you and you know
stories so there was kind of maybe you
can kind of educate me on this but red
pill used to be associated with
just um
maybe anti-establishment views I don't
know uh maybe maybe a republican
conservative Viewpoint people yeah right
yeah they use red pill a lot in like
different communities like when you say
the red pill Community yeah that's
usually means dating the dating thing
but a lot of people say oh Trump voters
the red pill are you Red pilled on like
politics whatever people say stuff like
that yeah okay cool and then there's
like the manosphere that's all the
similar type of stuff and Andrew Tate is
somebody that represents kind of the
figurehead of the manosphere of like the
red pill stuff yeah I would say so I'm
pretty sure yeah okay all right cool so
uh what are some ideas that they
represent and what do you think about
them I think they do a good job at
speaking to disaffected young men who
feel like the rest of the world has kind
of left them behind or isn't willing to
speak to them and they do Identify some
true and real problems feels like on the
left we have a really hard time doing
like self-improvement or telling people
how to better themselves we focus too
much on like structural or systemic
issues rather than what can an
individual do to uplift or Empower
themselves and it also feels like they
do a good job at speaking to some of the
positive aspects of masculinity that
it's okay to be like strong and brave
and a soldier and a warrior and provide
for your family and blah blah blah um
types of like those are like positive
messages like self-improvement and
everything that come from the red pill
Community what's the negative
I think the analysis on how men and
women interact is a way to transactional
all of like the Romanticism and love and
chemistry has totally sucked out of it
everything is very like sex based like
how do you basically have sex with the
most amount of women possible and that's
going to make you happy
um and then I think people's motivation
sometimes are just spoken about in such
a shallow derogatory way that I don't
think is always reflective of reality
like a woman only wants you because you
make six figures and you're tall and a
guy only wants you because he wants to
have sex with you like it feels like
there's a lot of that going on a lot
yeah and that misses some fundamental
aspect about relationships about
meaningful relationships and so on I
don't think I've never heard red pill
people ever ever talk about like
meaningful relationships it's always
just how to get in one or how to have
sex really
malware bothers you about some of that
philosophy I feel like people that are
like are like pill people I feel like
their solution is something that doesn't
actually work out
like where it work out it works out for
some people people that makes a lot of
money is like really successful in that
sort of way but it's not going to help
most men out there so I feel like it's
just like a pointless like speech to
give to these like really lost guys and
they really do believe that they can
like they can become successful they can
uh get money and like and when they get
all these things they can get girls but
most of them is not gonna achieve that
ever to get the money part or become
successful just become a billionaire you
know like and you'll get all the girls
and which is true but not everyone can
do that so I feel like when these guys
are speaking to these men and they're
just like we just care about these men
out there you know they need to hear
this it doesn't really help a lot of
them and it doesn't
um Inspire them to develop compassion
towards the opposite sex which is
probably something required to have that
is for a relationship and also like they
they seem to complain a lot about women
um like only wanting men that have money
and that's tall and that's muscular
whatever you know all those things
um and but they complain about that but
that's like also kind of what they're
trying to
make the men try to do for themselves so
they kind of like fall into the same
sort of behavior and it seems like
they're kind of unaware of that as well
um they're just playing a part of the
game instead of trying to find a woman
that doesn't look for those things and
that are looking for
not those things yeah I actually would
love to have like straight up data
on
people in that world versus not in that
world how often they get laid Yeah like
literally so
I think for sure people in that world
have fewer meaningful long-term
relationships that are fulfilling they
actually help them succeed in life that
help them be happy and content and all
that kind of stuff but just even the
straight up the the shallow goal of
getting laid
I wonder because it's very possible that
like just the the roughness with which
they uh treat intellectually women that
might lead to lower success not higher
success it's very adversarial which I
think is always disappointing anything
that talks about men and women I think
it's good to acknowledge differences but
when it becomes like adversarial
especially when you talk about sex sex
is something that men are getting and
it's something that women are giving and
that type of like trade-off and the way
they talk about it is like yeah it sets
people against each other in a really
toxic way I think
how do you talk to people from that
world from the red pill world like would
you would you ever talk to like somebody
like Andrew Tate oh yeah if I had a
chance to I've been on the uh fresh and
fit podcast three times and then I've
got a friend sneako who's like very red
pill that stuff um
if I'm trying to talk to them usually
the
um it's kind of like approaching a like
a scared cat the first thing you have to
do is like be very gentle and say like I
understand your issues I understand your
complaints I know that you're I'm scary
because you think I'm gonna say like
toxic masculinity and feminism and all
these scary words that you um so the
first thing is always to recognize it
like a lot of what they talk about there
are like true aspects to what they're
talking about that people on the left
won't recognize so I think it's good to
acknowledge those things that like men
and women are kind of different we do
look for different things in general
when it comes to relationships it's okay
to say that it's not there's something
bad there and then it'll usually be like
once I've got your trust and I'm in your
bubble like let's talk about the things
that you want and maybe like some of the
strategies that you're employing aren't
necessarily going to get you some of the
things that you want so for instance if
you're really worried about like shallow
girls like ruining your life like Molina
said
um it's probably not best to build your
entire world view around trying to get
shallow girls that are going to ruin
your life like if your way of attracting
a girl is to go to the gym get a whole
bunch of money and try to like flaunt
your wealth as much as possible you're
going to be attracting the very same
type of women that you're here like
decrying on your stream yeah I think
we've talked about that on the podcast
like you probably want to have a woman
that's going to be there if you lose
your job it's still there like that
cares about the things that's not just
your job yeah
um it's more stable and also I don't
help you become a great man
uh great like grow like I feel like a
great friendship and a partnership like
it helps you make you a better person
some of the most successful people I
know I mean they have families and
there's clearly Dynamic there that's
like that makes them they wouldn't be
that without they're not an island yeah
yeah and uh the kid's actually a big
part of that too like for most people if
you're like a good parent they make you
step up somehow in life you have to take
responsibility for getting your [ __ ]
together and excelling in ways that uh
I guess the philosophy of the Red Bull
does not quite get to that's always an
interesting I think I've asked that a
couple times where it's like would you
let your daughter date Andrew Tate and
it's always funny to watch them kind of
like squirm around those answers
sometimes but see if they if they don't
have a daughter like I you know I don't
have a daughter I think your whole
philosophy changes once you have a
daughter sure like they can they know
that what they're answering they feel a
little bit weird about it it's funny to
watch them like they even they know it's
like ah [ __ ] you know well they they
might say like I I want my daughter to
date like a high value male
to the degree that he's a high value
male yes but like I don't think you'll
feel that way the definition of high
value change is completely certainly the
stereotypical
measures the value contribute to the
calculation but is so much more than
that I think on the chemistry of the
whole thing is is bigger